sometimes it doesn't take too much
to be right back there in the emotions
and how do you decompress
by learning the next scene for the next
day
um because there's no time to dwell
uh there's no time to sit back and go
yeah that was
yeah that was that was yeah that was
good that was great you know and
pat each other on the back because
you've got to do the same thing again
tomorrow you know and don't let yourself
down now
there are loads of untold stories about
this country
um the americans you know and a lot of
the
the rest of the world you talk to them
about english culture and they know from
the news but in terms of
our our history
um they can't pick too many things to
point at
you know so um a role like this comes
along
um lenora bless her she's telling me
about her father
12 years ago 13 years ago and i knew at
the time this was a story that needed to
be told you know
it's a true london story
and i love those i love i love when
they're real i love when they have heart
soul i love when there's a message
um you know this was one of those
stories so it was only a matter of time
um i also as i said to her a couple of
months ago
between you and me said to her that
i'm going to play that role one day
that's certainly what i was thinking in
my head when she told me
she's telling me the story and i'm
thinking yeah good
that's me that's going to be me um
seriously you know
so years later when it turned up you
know it's one of those things where
the signs the signal had been put out
and
and it turned up in my life and i'm very
honored and
very lucky um and i hope we see
more london stories you know more
english stories
uh for the world to look at and make up
their own mind
what if lenora had said no to you
playing her dad
well um unfortunately well that's when
you realize fortunately
you know we had a good time 12 years ago
this is why be careful
you know when you're when you're on the
way up you know
be careful who you who you talk to and
how you talk to them
because fortunately we did get on um and
i got a lovely photograph
from her and her mother on day one of
shooting you know one of those kind of
like
you know good luck kind of things as if
i wasn't under pressure already
um but uh no it was lovely
it's it's been a lovely kind of um
completion
of uh of that tale as it were you know
and speaking of personal projects will
lead how much did baghdad
central speak to you when you first
heard about it
similar to sean it was one of those
things where
all the stars were connecting
but in a weird way because when i first
got the uh
the audition i i was just
very skeptical i just felt like it was
going to be another
stereotype um middle eastern role
in western you know media
and then also i i had just lost my
father like about
three months before so i was
really not in a in a good place and had
a very negative filter but
once i kind of removed that filter and
and just
really you know looked at the role and
what was really behind it it was
everything that i
was looking for um and you know i
i uh i lived in kuwait when iraq invaded
so i was
at 19 years old and so i had the
experience
of living through a war and through an
invasion and
um so it was very personal to me you
know and it was something that kind of
catapulted my adulthood so those are
experiences you just never really forget
and uh i i just had a feeling like
once i kind of you know removed that
filter that you know nobody else can
play this role
it's um like i was i was born to play
this role
that was the feeling um so yeah very
very personal
how did you prepare mentally to return
to
a war zone even though of course it
wasn't a real one but it was
it was well unfortunately
the war's still going on so
it was i mean all he had to really do is
turn on the tv or just dig into what's
happening in iraq and as
as late as january 2020 when when we
premiered
at the bfi film festival you know before
covid
um demonstrations were breaking out at a
you know accelerated pace and so we were
like wow the story really needs to get
out so that people
understand um the roots of
of what we're currently seeing today and
and um yeah i mean so it was
it was uh something that was very
current
it was like a period piece that was in
within our lifetime
the writer who wrote the novel which is
the series is based on
elliot cola uh just a remarkable human
being and his wife is iraqi
and he based my character really on his
father-in-law
there's a lot of of his in his
father-in-law so it was very personal to
him too and we got to meet
and and that just made it such an
organic process and then stephen
bouchard who's
an incredible writer just um
elevated everything uh and so much of it
was just
something you know i i just felt in the
writing and in the nuance
there were choices that i would make um
as the character but also as waleed so
it just felt very
very natural and then and then most of
it was just about connecting with this
incredible cast that we had
really incredible cast our directors
were phenomenal
um and it was just a real pleasure
as as hard work as it was it was so much
fun every day
all of these roles are so intense
actually i think if you're kind of
playing that character all the way
you know days at a time how do you
leave that behind if you have a day off
or just going to sleep
i didn't really have a day off um
um i didn't i didn't i think i had one
day off
and so um it's interesting that you
asked that because
actually um
i also um lost my father a few years ago
and so
these kind of uh emotions were still
you have to kind of scratch the surface
too much you know before
you know not the hulk but the you know
it's it's like you're always angry
it's it's one of those things where you
know you you
certainly with a role like that you have
to um go to certain places
but but but you don't have to go that
far
um but unfortunately
you know when we think about loved ones
and we think about the horrors of the
planet
uh and whatever else as i say
sometimes it doesn't take too much
to be right back there in the emotions
and how do you decompress
by learning the next scene for the next
day
um because there's no time to dwell
uh there's no time to sit back and go
yeah that was
yeah that was that was yeah that was
good that was great you know and
pat each other on the back because
you've got to do the same thing again
tomorrow you know and don't let yourself
down now
um i don't know how the others think but
uh that's certainly my
take on on what we were doing so i
really didn't have a day off i didn't
have time to meditate
like let alone to have a day off and and
and i that's usually how i ground myself
so it was and it was trial by fire for
me because this was my
let alone like not only my first lead
but my first series regular
so it was uh it was
and you know so much of of that
was the adrenaline that was driving me
through it
because of the excitement and and i
didn't even feel like the responsibility
like i was like bring it on you know the
responsibility that's
this is what i've always wanted to play
and it's a
it's a it's a heroic arab role so
um i was like okay great um
my work is cut out and but it got to the
point where and my wife was
visiting to witness it but i just i just
i i got really burnt out
and luckily the um uh the head executive
producer kate harwood was visiting
morocco at the time and i told her i
said
i need a break i'm i'm i'm
and one of the things that i think i
learned in my journey on this
was and and i think some of this is also
in that
anger post my father's death and
and i think it was like um i didn't want
to
not be honest anymore yeah i was done
trying to please people and i
it was really like self-preservation but
i'm so glad i asked for it because
i did get a break because there's
a you know it's like you're you're
mirroring what the character is going
through and it's to a certain point
where it's very hopeful but then
it it it becomes counterproductive like
i was starting to
be angry on set and i remember i
actually spoke to the director of the
second block
uh ben and he was so supportive and i
said listen i'm
i cannot make uh this afternoon scene i
actually said i couldn't make
the scenes today this was after i was in
the makeup trailer
and then and he totally respected and he
goes do me a favor can you show up for
this afternoon's
uh scene and i said yeah i'm gonna go
and get some sleep
and i'll be here this afternoon
[Music]
you